his royal highness the duke of edinburgh
born out of windsor castle
it was the house of windsor that he
served
and he leaves it now his duty done
carried by soldiers of the grenadier
guards of queen's company
placed upon his standard the sword that
was given to him by king george
vi when he married princess elizabeth in
1947
and his cap as an apple
the flowers from her majesty the queen
and the royal family
and the heraldic devices of denmark and
greece
mountbatten and of the city of edinburgh
from which great city in scotland he
took his name as duke
of edinburgh
the bearer party commanded by lieutenant
alec haywood
whose grandfather commanded the queen's
company
grenadier guards at the funeral of king
george vi
and also at the coronation
when prince philip knelt before her
majesty the queen
and said i philip to become your liege
man of life and limb
and of earthly worship of faith and
truth
i will bear unto thee to live and die
against all manner of folk
so help me god with which he stood
kissed the queen on the cheek and
touched her crown
to promise his life of service
with care and devotion to their former
colonel
queen's company the grenadier guards
have done their duty
as the royal family have gathered behind
to follow the cortege
down to the chapel
the duke's four children prince of wales
the princess royal
the duke of york and the earl of wessex
and forther
grandchildren the duke of cambridge
peter phillips
and the duke of sussex
and also
lord snowden and sir tim lawrence
as we await the arrival of her majesty
the queen
you